SEAN ROBINSON: For us, in
practice, in the teaching lab,
we try to get the
students the information
they need at the time when
they're most ready to learn it.
Let's take one example
of one of the skills
which takes some
time to develop,
which is analyzing data.
Data analysis is hard.
Nobody has good
intuition for it.
It involves mathematics.
It involves somewhat of
a dark art of skills.
So everybody requires
practice at it.
Several years ago, our approach
to teaching data analysis
in Junior Lab was we
would have a few lectures.
We would take the first hour
and a half of each lab session
on the first couple of
days of the semester,
and just lecture
to the students.
We would give a blackboard talk
or a PowerPoint presentation,
and tell them
everything there is
to know that would get them at
least through a semester or two
of Junior Lab.
Now of course,
nobody would remember
any of that by the time
it came to actually do
data analysis sometime in the
next few weeks after that.
And given everything we
know about how people learn,
that is not at all surprising.
So the way we do
this now is there
is a little bit of instruction,
either by some reading
or a video on the web, which is
mediated through the open EdX
platform on MITx.
They do a little
bit of what amounts
to a reading quiz on MITx.
But that's when--
we don't necessarily
believe that watching someone
give a lecture on a computer
screen is much better than
giving a lecture in person,
not necessarily.
So we believe the
real learning is
going to happen
the next day when
they come to the
classroom, and we're
going to do some sort
of very active exercise
on this very same material which
they just learned overnight.
So the direct
instruction that happens
as part of the
preparation, we really
are treating it as
the preparation.
It's not the main learning.
The main learning is going to
happen with the active exercise
that happens in class.
But we just need
to have some sort
of priming so that
when they arrive,
they are ready to
start that learning.